the best ways to kick off the new year
is to declutter the chaos in our homes
and HGTV host and lifestyle expert
breegan Jane is here welcome thank you
for having me it is so cool to have you
on the show such a fan and there's a lot
of you designers here in town huh we
have taken over Vegas this week there
are six different shows happening right
now the designers are in town well we
are so lucky to have you on Las Vegas
now today and a lot of people are going
into the new year and they're like I
just I want to start fresh I need to
declutter and you say this can happen in
just three easy steps talk to us this is
so easy but it's the thing we all avoid
everyone wants me to design their house
but nobody wants to deal with the stuff
that I have to take out and put back in
can't you just do that I I have some
stats and one is to not get overwhelmed
I think that this is something we put
off because it's going to be
uncomfortable so setting your timer for
30 minutes and focusing on one space is
a great place to start I actually like
that it's like making it a smaller
project that's attainable instead of a
big one that you're never going to
finish and you're never going to regret
it my favorite place to do is the
bathroom and what I start with is I just
take everything out of the drawers yeah
because then I know I have to put it
back right that's brilliant okay don't
get overwhelmed step number one what's
two toss the trash you can't out
organize yourself from stuff and too
much stuff so it doesn't matter how
perfectly you line it in trays if you
are just putting the junk back into the
drawer it's going to find its way into
clutter all over again so it's really
about getting getting rid of things
giving them away and donating so you
know we always have those items we want
to keep but you're like I think my
friend would really like this so I
always kind of have this in between
giveaway pile for the sentimental stuff
that I'm too tied to my my whole way of
thinking is if I haven't used it in the
last year I'm probably never going to
use it so let's get rid of it and some
some are better at this naturally than
the others so just go with the flow but
get rid of get rid of half of it if you
can okay these seem easy step number
three is it sentimental or is it just
stuff and as a designer I see people try
to design their homes instead of think
about what things mean to them and
there's often these little moments in
our home where we're like that's not in
style but your grandmother gave it to
you yes we can do this and make it
beautiful but I want to know what those
moments are so for yourself when you're
going through your home don't think is
this on Trend does this look good does
this mean something to me and then it
should be on a shelf the way you break
it down it just seems so easy to do I
love it you are fantastic thank you so
much for joining us have a great time
while you're here thank you thank you
for having me I love it we'll send it
over to you Rocky thank